Crunchyroll is trying to fool you well
okay sort of let me explain so
Crunchyroll is putting out a new set of
Dragon Ball Z Blu-rays how exciting
right well not exactly they aren't
actually new at all so these new Dragon
Ball Z Blu-rays that are now listed by
Crunchyroll are in fact actually
reprints of the old Dragon Ball Z
Blu-rays FUNimation have been putting
out for years now so why are they
reprinting these as separate entities
well to put it simply because
Crunchyroll bought out FUNimation and as
a result they want a DBZ release with
their name plastered all over the front
so yeah if you had seen this upcoming
release and hoped we'd finally be
getting a good Dragon Ball Z release in
the west well
so for now we are still stuck with the
16x9 cropped over contrasted noise
reduced to Hell releases were used to